Okay wait,
I just
learned something
that's kind of blowing my mind.
The reason
why there are so many
Thai restaurants in the United States
is because the government of Thailand
wanted there to be.
In 2002,
the government of Thailand, launched
this program to train Thai chefs
and then to invest in them
opening restaurants in other countries.
And it was at this time in 2002
that they chose pad thai
to be their national dish.
And it totally worked.
Now, there are thousands
and thousands more
Thai restaurants here in our country
and around the world
because of this effort.
Some people call it
“gastrodiplomacy,” using food as a way
to spread the goodness of your culture
and your country
to the rest of the world.
And I think it's freaking awesome.
Thank you, Thailand.
If you want to better understand
global politics and stuff like this,
follow along for more.